es braucht bin ich da drauf charles
drauf kurz springt packt das
notwendigste zu sagen das wichtigste hat
er auf seine festplatte gespeichert als
alle ganze dokumentation und aber alle
fotos unterlagen kurz springen bereitet
sich auf eine mögliche evakuierung vor
alles kommt ins wohnmobil kleidung
lebensmittel in seinem dorf fühlt er
sich nicht mehr sicher
am anfang war es respekt dann neue
unsicherheit aber in letzter zeit haben
wir auch schlichtweg
[Musik]
das bergdorf brienz im schweizerischen
graubünden ein idyllischer fleck kurz
spring wohnt ihr seit 29 jahren
doch seit einiger zeit ist hier nichts
mehr wie es einmal war
viele einwohner sind verunsichert priens
wird gleich von zwei gefahren bedroht
der boden auf dem das dorf steht rutscht
richtung tal ein meter 20 pro jahr
einige häuser zerreißt es regelrecht
dieses musste inzwischen abgerissen
werden
gerutscht ist das dorf zwar schon seit
jahrzehnten so schlimm wie jetzt war es
aber noch nie zugleich droht ein
gigantischer berg sturz er könnte das
dorf mit seinen knapp 100 einwohnern
verschütten
das macht kurz springt am meisten sorgen
die vorboten liegen am ortseingang
riesige felsbrocken im sommer 2009 10
stürzte dieser herunter wie durch ein
wunder blieb kurz vor dem spielplatz
liegen
das donnern beim absturz hatte kurz
springen in seinem keller gehört mir
gedanken waren sind sofort kommen wie
viele steine
was ist es wie viel common control
bewerbung für ganze werk trifft ist das
haustier ist es die häuser wissen dass
spielplatz trifft ist das alte schulhaus
das sind die gedanken die ersten
gedanken die die wir haben
der berg wird rund um die uhr überwacht
rader gps messungen drohnen aufnahmen
jede noch so kleine bewegung wird
erfasst
alles maßnahmen um die bewohner
rechtzeitig zu warnen wenn kurz spring
den berg sieht denkt er an andere
verheerende berg stürze wie zum beispiel
in bondo in graubünden 2017
lebensgefährte als sieben mal mehr als
bürger grund kommen
das sagt genug in bondo stürzten damals
millionen kubikmeter schutt und geröll
in die tiefe acht wanderer kamen ums
leben
das dorf wurde teilweise zerstört oder
edle in dem wallis 2015
kann man fans und berg stürze besser
vorhersagen
am matterhorn wird daran geforscht
eine besondere idee hatte der
geowissenschaftler jan beutel von der
eth zürich und universität innsbruck
zusammen mit kollegen von weiteren
schweizer universitäten wollen sie in
den berg hinein hören ob ein felssturz
droht ihr felslabor auf dreieinhalb
tausend metern höhe die instrumente
müssen sie regelmäßig überprüfen
wir sind hier mal haben weil wir einen
kleinen jack machen es ist hauptsächlich
software und müssen die batterie
auswechseln in einem sensor es geht
steil bergauf
seit zwölf jahren überwachen die
forscher matterhorn die feld stabilität
ihre beobachtung beunruhigend felsstürze
nehmen zu der berg ist in bewegung wie
zum beispiel die rechte feld spitze im
bild viereinhalb zentimeter pro jahr
richtung zusammen und das ist
außergewöhnlich viel für so einen fels
verankerten normalerweise würde man
erwarten dass sowas vielleicht im
bereich von ein paar millimetern pro
jahr sich bewegt aber das ist eben ein
zeichen dass das ganze gefüge schon ein
stabiles den wegen des klimawandels taut
permafrost auf das ist der kitt der die
berge im innersten zusammenhält das
matterhorn wird immer brüchiger 2003
sind zwei bis 3000 kubikmeter fels hier
abgestürzt wir sehen hier oben diesen
weißen fleck in den felsen evans genau
die abbruch zone 3000 kubikmeter geröll
so viel wie etwa drei einfamilienhäuser
um solche felsstürze künftig besser
vorherzusagen haben sie zahlreiche
messgeräte installiert die sensoren
messen jede bewegung und jede schwingung
die forscher versuchen die schwingungen
der felsen zu entschlüsseln
damit hören sie in den berg hinein
klingt erstmal nach einer verrückten
idee in der schwarzen tonne ist der
schlüssel dazu
das ist unser seismische sensor mit dem
wir hier haben den ton des berges die
sprache eines berges verstehen wollen
denn jede fels partie hat ein bestimmtes
schwingungs muster dieses kann man
hörbar machen hier mehrfach verstärkt so
klingt das matterhorn die töne können
unterschiedlich sein einem glas wasser
das eben mit verschiedenen 5 stand an
unterschiedlichen ton gibt wenn man
daran glaubt ist das hier auch als ein
großes volumen hat einen tiefen ton und
wenn es nur hohe töne centern sind das
kleine wohnungen hier ist der fels das
glas wasser ist der riss klein ist auch
die fans partie die frei schwingen kann
kleiner und erzeugt einen höheren ton
wird er es größer wird auch der ton
tiefer
wenn wir hier bei den seismischen
messungen eine eine starke veränderung
beobachten zb einen doppelt so tiefen
ton registrieren würden dann ist das ein
anzeichen dass sich möglicherweise ein
felssturz an wand mit der stimme des
berges einem bergsturz vorhersagen jan
beutel möchte seine forschung noch an
anderen bergen erproben
[Musik]
in brienz ist diese messmethode
versuchsweise im einsatz
der evakuierungsplan für das bergdorf
steht kurz springen und seiner nachbarin
sind bereits die notunterkünfte in den
nachbardörfern zugeteilt worden
der zeitplan für die evakuierung wurde
nochmals verschärft
da bleibt wenig zeit kurz springen würde
gerne wegziehen doch an einen verkauf
seines hauses ist nicht zu denken denn
wer zieht schon freiwillig in ein akutes
gefahrengebiet 20 personen jetzt 87 im
dorf also wer ist dann werde ich schon
lange gefährlich ist es auch hier auf
der wissen scheinen berg im mattertal im
wallis mit dem auftauen des permafrosts
zerbröselt dieser berg regelrecht
[Musik]
jan beutel ist heute mit einem
mitarbeiter seines teams hier oben auf
3200 metern höhe ein messgerät ist
ausgefallen und muss dringend repariert
werden
es herrscht akute steinschlaggefahr so
groß werden dass sie die gebäude das
schulhaus die kirche erreichen und
deshalb wurden hier erhebliche
investitionen getätigt das ist aber
nicht genug weil sich eben der ganze
hang bewegt man muss sich vorstellen
wenn sich fällen 50 zentimeter im jahr
bewegen dann ist das eine große
bedrohung treffen würde es vor allem den
ort randa im tal der defekte sensor
macht jan beutel sorgen zusammen mit
seinen kollegen hat er ein gps sensoren
netzwerk entwickelt um den berg zu
überwachen
alle messdaten fließen automatisch in
das frühwarnsystem der behörden mit ein
ohne den sensor fielen wichtige daten
zum schutz der bevölkerung
wir sehen ob sich die geschwindigkeit
beschleunigt ob eventuell mehr felssturz
ein größerer feldschütz droht der
möglicherweise den siedlungsraum und die
verkehrswege erreichen kann
eine heikle tour für die beiden das kids
aber auch für euch ein gefährlicher
einsatz oder das ist auf jeden fall so
also man sieht beim laufen dann muss
sich abstützen
die steine rutschen man ist fast am
limit wanderer länder ist es sicher
keines die steinschlag netze eine
spezielle konstruktion
sie sind in 25 metern tiefe verankert im
permafrost
das besondere sie passen sich an die
bewegung des berges an dass eine
spezielle technik wo eigentlich der hang
unter den netzen durch rutschen können
man die stützen immer wieder gerade auf
den richtigen punkt nachjustiert oben am
schutznetz war das defekte gerät
befestigt verantwortlich für die
funkkommunikation deshalb konnten die
daten des gps sensors nicht ins tal
gesendet werden
die beiden müssen ist austauschen das
sind unsere verknoten die hier die
funkkommunikation sicherstellen und im
winter ist eine von diesen aus der
halterung rausgefallen werden
wahrscheinlich keinen starken sturm und
beim sturz kaputt gegangen
in zukunft werden noch viel mehr berge
mit überwachungssystemen ausgestattet
werden müssen
jan beutel nennt dies die anpassung an
die folgen des klimawandels denn wegen
der erderwärmung werden steinschläge und
felsstürze zu nehmen so die prognose der
forscher in brillant sind steinschlag
netze keine lösung der berg bewegt sich
hier sehr viel stärker als in anderen
gebieten sechs meter pro jahr gewaltige
kräfte
diese würden die schutzbauten innerhalb
kürzester zeit zerstören
oben auf dem gipfel kann man sehen wie
der fels zerbricht
vor vier jahren war diese stelle noch
völlig intakt man muss sich vorstellen
da unten konnte man noch bequem
durchgehen es hatte rechts und links
kompakte große felsblöcke aber das war
nie so aufgelöst wie das jetzt heute
nach liegt
inzwischen wird in kleinen briens großes
geschütz aufgefahren
die behörden unternähmen alles um das
dorf zu retten
auf dem berg finden mehrere bohrungen
statt
nadelstiche in den berg
forscher wollen herausfinden warum der
berg so instabil ist
dieses gestein stammt das knapp 300
metern tiefe hier haben wir einen eine
weiche schicht dazwischen und hier einen
übergang vermutlich zu einem anderen
gestein und das gibt uns aufschluss über
die mechanismen in der rutsche
diese maßnahmen können kurz springen
nicht die sorgen nehmen denn aufhalten
können sie einen möglichen bergsturz
nicht er möchte nur eines endlich wieder
in ruhe schlafen können
eigentlich möchten wir mit das
versuchsobjekt der gemeinde seien und
der wissenschaft sein sondern wir werfen
einfach wie in ruhe wohnen und hier zwei
oder umgesetzt werden
und da in ruhe unterhalten gewesen
[Musik]
kommt der berg oder kommt er nicht kurz
springt jedenfalls ist für den ernstfall
vorbereitet für die bewohner von brienz
ist es ein leben mit der gefahr
[Musik]